games and let's begin with the tampa bay
buccaneers hosting the minnesota vikings
an old nfc central reunion game
vikings at bucks after a week off peter
brady and the bucks will be what versus
the vikings
red hot i think i think that brady comes
back with a healthier receiving crew
probably since he's had all since he's
had all season mike
and to me i think they're gonna play
really well
uh i think they're gonna win that game
by double digits
i agree with you completely the vikings
don't have the defense to pressure brady
up the middle they don't have the
secondary to cover mike evans chris
godwin antonio brown
and rob gronkowski and i don't think
they have the running game
to overcome a great tampa bay
defense and without the running game all
due respect to dalvin cook but this is
the best rush defense in the nfl that
they are going to be facing without that
running game
kirk cousins can't get it done this is a
bad spot for the vikings and this is
where
their incredible turnaround from one in
five to six and six
comes to an end and the bucks get to
eight and five
and thrust themselves even deeper into
the playoff conversation and bruce arian
said earlier this week home field
advantage doesn't matter
this year because fans aren't going to
be at the games so
it's just where you play it you don't
get that edge by having a home game so
the bucks could be dangerous in the
postseason on the road
cardinals on the road at metlife stadium
six and six arizona taking on the five
and seven giants a few weeks ago
this was an easy check the win column
for the cardinals now
it's not and so peter after frustrating
russell wilson the giants defense will
do
what against kylo murray build the exact
same spider web around
kyler murray that they built around
russell wilson you know i talked to
leonard williams of the giants after the
game the other day
and he talked about uh patrick graham
the defensive coordinator
and what a good job he does putting them
in position the way they
he put them in position to sort of
surround
and frustrate russell wilson i think
it'll be the exact
same game plan with some tweaks
obviously
against kyler murray and one other thing
mike every year we
probably talked about this earlier this
year but every year when the schedule
comes out
this year it came out in early may and
every year you look at the schedule
and you say oh they're just playing this
team this team this team
we don't think about when the games are
played
if the arizona cardinals had had to take
a trip to the meadowlands
on september 11th instead of december
13th or whatever whatever the dates are
if they had had to go there back in in
september
i mean i think they would have won the
game perhaps handily
now i think it's you know flip a coin
for this game
but it really does depend
when you face teams as you look at a
schedule over the course of the season
and just amazing to see the giants in
the thick of things this year
after the struggles they had early in
the season but when you look back on
their schedule
they weren't being embarrassed like
other teams have been
right they played the steelers much
closer than than
the final score would suggest they gave
the rams everything they could handle
but but they have put it together
and they have a chance to get to six and
seven i just hope one of these nfc east
teams at least gets to 500
to win the division but uh yeah i agree
with you it's a coin flip game
a few weeks ago it wouldn't look that
way the cardinals have now lost four out
of five they'd be on a five-game losing
streak but for the hail murray
they need to avoid a four-game losing
streak since that
miraculous play from last month against
the bills
washington five and seven 49ers five and
seven
washington tied for first place in the
nfc east they're technically in second
because of the tiebreaker they were
swept by the giants
49ers still very much alive
they could still finish nine and seven
they could still sneak into the
postseason and one of the things we've
seen from them this year when they have
a bad game
they respond fairly well so peter after
shocking
the steelers alex smith and the
washington football team
are what to you
a totally mysterious team
but a team that easily could win the nfc
east
and this game you're right mike this
game is a totally fascinating game
i think it's the hardest game to read of
this weekend
because of the how mercurial
san francisco is but i will say this
i think this is a week that the 49ers
will
really miss george kittle because
this is a week where nick mullins is not
going to have
the kind of time he has in a normal week
to find his good receivers downfield
you know i think this is the kind of
week that
he gets pressured a lot both from
inside the sa washington defensive front
and from the edge as well and so to me
i think this is a game where nick
mullins is going to have to make
some throws down field that he'd much
rather make
to george kittle in the intermediate
part of the field
and let's not forget even though trent
williams now the 49ers left tackle has
buried the hatchet with
washington because they got rid of
everybody who was there when trent
williams had a bad experience
kyle shanahan the coach of the 49ers
still takes a
very high degree of delight in getting
an opportunity
to play and to beat daniel snyder's team
remember last year
when they won that game in washington in
a rainstorm and it was old school
and it was mud and it was it was water
and it was great
game ball went to mike shanahan after
the 49ers
beat washington so maybe there'll be
another game ball going to mike shanahan
on sunday if the 49ers pull it off all
right the packers
going to ford field to take on the lions
green bay nine and three
trying to get the one seed if they can
catch the saints in the standings
green bay gets the one seed by virtue of
a week three victory
over new orleans the lions after beating
the bears last week somehow
five and seven they're not dead either
so after pulling to within
one game back of the number seven seed
the detroit lions are
what versus aaron rodgers and the
packers peter
i don't know cooked geese is that
is that fair to say i mean to me i i
don't
i don't see how they're gonna win this
game even
in detroit and i don't think it's going
to take the hail mary that it took
several years ago
you know for for aaron rodgers to have
enough points in this game
it's all well and good for the lions to
be doing ding dong the witch is dead
now that they got daryl bevel instead of
uh
matt patricia but you still got to
figure out two things
who's covering davonte adams and who's
gonna pressure
aaron rodgers enough to turn make him
make three or four mistakes
to give you a chance to win i don't
think either going to turn out well for
detroit the lions have played the
packers well in detroit they did get a
lift last week when they somehow beat
the bears and daryl bevel has a year
with aaron rodgers now i don't know that
that one year of experience with aaron
rodgers is going to make a damn bit of
difference other than to make bevel
realize what he's in for and bevel said
that
rogers currently is playing as well as
any quarterback has ever played in the
history of the national football
league and you know what he's right and
sims can make the argument even though
he has made patrick mahomes the best
quarterback in the nfl in his rankings
this year sims is making a persuasive
argument that rogers is the mvp peter
when you think about it
rogers doesn't have the help around him
that patrick mahomes does
and rogers is phenomenal this year so
uh i i think there's something to be
said for the possibility of rogers
ultimately winning the mvp especially if
the packers get the one seed all right
the jets
oh and 12 going to seattle to take on a
seahawks team that
somehow found a way to lose to the
giants jamal adams
former jet safety very anxious for this
matchup
after nearly upsetting the raiders the
jets chances of giving
seattle a fight on sunday are what peter
3.74
um because i just found that they do
give me the under
they do not have they don't have the
ability
to do to uh russell wilson
what the new york giants had and i also
think
that jamal adams this sunday
is going to set the nfl record with 174
blitzes in a single football game
and that would be a record wouldn't it
mike 117
i think jamal adams is going to set that
record
yes there would be many records set in
the game if he's able to blitz 174 times
peter this is a horrible situation for
the jets right i mean think about it
they had their shot to win
they lost in spectacular fashion the
defensive equivalent of the miracle in
the meadowlands play
right where where they you hand off
instead of victory formation i mean you
you send everybody instead of guard the
end zone you can't recover from that and
fly cross country and muster
the will to win against a team that just
got
caught napping by the giants
shaquille griffin said yesterday
they took the giants lightly of course
they did they're not going to take the
jets lightly
the jets are are the raw meat thrown to
the lions
who uh forfeited their last meal so
this is just bad bad bad this is the one
game this weekend that i feel the
strongest about seattle will win i think
seattle will cover of course that
probably means the jets will win
straight up but i i'd be stunned if the
seahawks lose this game
they should be there should be some sort
of provision in the rules where if you
have an embarrassing loss consecutive
embarrassing losses in december
whatever your record otherwise is you
don't get to go to the playoffs i'm
exaggerating but
if the seahawks have no business in the
postseason if they lose to both new york
teams at home
in consecutive weeks peter
not gonna happen but mike you forgot the
best jets highlight of the week
the very very great jets highlight of
the week and do you know what that is
the jets candidate for walter payton man
of the year
a month ago there is nothing more
jets than making pierre dazir
the walter payton man of the year
candidate when he hasn't been in your
building for a month
yeah that that is uh that is something
and you would think there would be some
procedure in place for an adjustment
because that
is the epitome of the jets this season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports